Google clouds AI platform training now
has built-in algorithms that you can use
to train models without writing a single
line of code let's dive in and find out
how you can use it
[Music]
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to use
AI platforms built-in algorithms to
train and deploy a machine learning
model without writing any training code
the tool acts as a handy wrapper around
AI platform training and it bridges the
gap between Auto ml and full custom
training jobs now as of this recording
this feature is still in beta but
perhaps if you're watching this in the
future it may already be generally
available now before we can really get
going on this we want to decide what it
is we're going to build a model for in
this case I've got here the US census
data set a classic binary classification
machine learning problem this means that
the goal will be to separate this data
into one of two groups in this case our
data comes from the 1994 US Census and
the task will be to predict if a given
household income will be above or below
$50,000 a year with this context in
place let's look at how we can use AI
platform training to train up this model
without writing any code to get started
with AI platform training using built-in
algorithms head on over to the jobs menu
in the cloud console and click on new
training job in that menu you will see
two options click on built-in algorithm
training the first step is to select our
algorithm currently there are a handful
of options mostly around structured data
though there are a few about images as
well which we won't cover today the
three structured data algorithms that
are currently available are XG boost a
linear learner and the wide and deep
learner as the names suggest XG boost
uses the popular implementation of
gradient boosted trees and while the
linear learner essentially models
something like linear regression and
finally the wide and deep learner
uses the tensorflow research model wide
and deep which tries to combine the
memorization benefits of a wide linear
model with the strong generalization
capabilities of deep neural networks
once you've selected an algorithm we
need to specify the training data this
system takes as input the Google Cloud
Storage URL path so your data will need
to be uploaded onto Google Cloud storage
beforehand and additionally for
structured data
this system is expecting specifically a
hairless CSV file and furthermore the
prediction target column must be the
very first column of that CSV file so it
may mean that you need to do a bit of
light pre-processing just to move things
around a bit and if your CSV file is
small enough to load into a spreadsheet
software of your choice I would
recommend just using that and dragging
your label column over into that first
column position then just delete that
header row if there is one and export
the file as a CSV file this is probably
the most straightforward way to generate
that appropriate output format the
system allows you to specify a
validation data and test data either as
separate files or as a percentage of the
training data so if your data is mixed
in all together using the percentages is
an easy and convenient way to ensure
that you have representative metrics if
you have separate files for training
validation and test make sure that all
three are representative of the same
reality otherwise your training results
so they might surprise you
so once you've specified all the
different training data the next screen
is all about specifying the algorithm
arguments this menu will differ
depending on which algorithm you choose
each one has a somewhat long list of
parameters that you can specify now
while many default values are provided
and there's also extensive documentation
for each value that you can set
additionally a lot of these parameters
are available to be used for hyper tune
which is Google cloud platforms hyper
parameter tuning service to use it
check the hyper tune box and provide a
lower and upper bound for the hyper
parameter that you want to have
system tuned for you be sure to check
off allow early stopping of hyper tune
trials this will allow you to take
advantage of early stopping of any
unpromising trials which will save
compute in time once your algorithm
arguments are set click Next and we just
have a few final details to provide
about the training job give it a job ID
region and select the scale tier and
then the training will commence while
the model is trading you can make a
coffee maybe read some web comics or
kick off another training job in
parallel since it's pretty light way to
start a training job you can try
different models and different parameter
ranges pretty easily once training is
complete you can click on the job to
view some of the details including
resource utilization as well as links to
stack driver logging you can also deploy
your model directly from that screen
there is a deployed model button at the
top which will grab the exported model
from Google Cloud storage for you and
deploy it out so you can have a REST API
to call your models for predictions so
there you have it an easy way to run
model training and deployment without
needing to write a single line of code
while still having the controls that you
want for adjusting the details of a
particular model this can save time
while still enabling you to get
high-quality results customized for your
use case and data set for more details
and examples check out the links I'm
included in the description below thanks
for watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures and if you enjoyed it click
that like button and be sure to
subscribe to get all the latest episodes
right when they come out for now check
out AI platform training using built-in
algorithms and see what kind of results
you can produce
you